you have done something quite remarkable
you have shot the first film entirely in
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia directed by
a woman I'm wondering if you could take
us through the rather historic journey
you went through because I know you were
raised in a very small village where
movies were banned I grew up watching a
lot of phones like because Saudi the
public exhibition of film is not allowed
but there is a lot of blockbuster VHS
when I was growing up so I remember my
father showed us a lot of film we are 12
kids so I can imagine the house we grew
up in it's crazy so we watch a lot of
film just to keep us quiet and when I
started educating myself when I wanted
to be a filmmaker and I watched a lot of
Iranian cinema and I thought it's
interesting how they project their
culture and how they they use a small I
small concepts that project more about
the culture and brings things like that
and I wanted to tell a story like this
and I was thinking and I the bicycle has
a lot of weight and cinematic history
like it's at the Bicycle Thief and all
that and and yet it's for me I wanted
also to be accepted back home I know
Saudis very conservative and they they
don't accept film as a form of art and
it's little own that a woman making film
is very offensive for the conservative
culture and I really want to be part of
making the country more tolerant people
more acceptance and just like an enjoy
of film and not to be that militant tell
us about some of the challenges you as a
woman director faced in just shooting a
movie in Saudi Arabia but because
challenges whenever we went outside the
country is segregated and I wasn't
allowed to be in the streets working
with men so I have to be always in a van
and they had a van a good van with us
with everything with a monitor and a
walkie-talkie but it's very like
frustrating not to be for for blocking
purposes or like you want to talk to the
actors and what would you do communicate
with walkie-talkies scream at everybody
like do this don't do that put the
camera I was like and for me it was like
you are in confined place you cannot
really escape and you want to change
things you know very now and then but
but it is such a rewarding experience
because it made me work harder and
really work with the actors and explain
the heart of the scene and this was a
great exercise for me I wouldn't have
gone there effort weren't for that like
situation that was the story of the last
shot when she is bicycling I wanted yeah
a landscape like urban that opens and
like she's bicycling and she opens to
like almost like a desert and we found
this only place in them the most
conservative place in and Saudi and you
know people in Saudi like the
Conservatives are very militant and they
would call their just police and they
will do a lot of stuff and and we went
there and we knew that we have a very
limiting fart time and lots the the GOP
was like mounted in this white man I'm
that like montant owner on a car in the
middle of Riyadh and why it was pedaling
and people started getting really mm not
angry but they were just like if almost
angry they're coming in from their
houses and they didn't want this to
happen there and their neighborhood but
I was really glad like him very quickly
that's like got a right and time before
there was just police comes and gets us
all I know I grabbed wide from front of
the camera literally because I would
lying to producers like yeah now you
have to leave and I grabbed her she was
a smiling this and this and that is the
end of it like I just took her front of
the camera and abdomen like the Abdullah
the guy who was playing and I didn't
worry about him because he's a boy he
was like hanging by the car by the van I
just left but it for me it was amazing
just the shooting and yeah because it I
come from originally from a small town
around Riyadh and for me it's like
almost coming home are there movie
theaters in Saudi that this film is
playing yet oh no there is no movie
theaters but we try to like organize
cultural seeing and showings and sell
tickets and have people enjoy what it is
to be to go on a film but I
commercial cinema liquor you go to a
mall with a movie with the popcorn still
is not it's not yet like Saudis are very
very conservative they won't and the
public exhibition of art not accepted
yet but hopefully in the future I think
I'm very hopeful so we'll see